when domestic abuse allegations came out
against Johnny Depp Warner Brothers was
forced to act by asking death to resign
from his role as Gellert kinderwald in
Fantastic Beasts the secrets of
Dumbledore the studio had to move fast
to find a replacement and gave Mass
Mickelson just two days to decide if he
could fill the role director David Yates
told The Hollywood Reporter I wanted
Mass to explore a version of Grindelwald
that suited his strengths as an actor
and that inevitably meant a departure
from what Johnny brought to the role
just a couple of months after the
movie's release a jury sided with Depp
in his highly publicized defamation
lawsuit against his ex-wife Amber Heard
once the trial was over Mickelson gave
death fans hope when he told deadline
obviously well now the course has
changed he won the suit the court case
so let's see if he comes back he might
I'm a big fan of Johnny I think he's an
amazing actor I think he did a fantastic
job however any potential sequels have
reportedly been stalled until further
notice